[Music]
blockchain is a disruptive technology
which is helping businesses worldwide to
streamline trade by simplifying the
sharing of data between businesses and a
trusted way efficiencies are introduced
that make a real difference lock chain
services are fundamental to this
streamlining because they enable
different businesses to collaborate
easily in a neutral environment the
blockchain provides a secure distributed
database that records and communicates
transactions between businesses in a way
that is efficient verifiable and
permanent two significant challenges are
inherent in blockchain transactions data
flow and interaction latency in each
business blockchain transactions have
counterparts in on-premises applications
and it's the flow of information between
the two which is key to a successful
integration also because blockchain
interactions are encrypted and
consensus-based
they take longer than typical
transactions and because a cloud-based
blockchain service is likely to be
geographically distant from an
on-premises system latency can be a
concern these data flow and interaction
latency challenges can be solved using
an asynchronous message driven
architecture the qualities of service
and platform coverage provided by ibm's
premier mq messaging software make it
ideal for performing disintegration meet
petra from the Department of Motor
Vehicles or DMV Petra has heard about a
new cloud-based blockchain application
which tracks all vehicles through its
lifecycle the DMV already has an
existing application used to send
reminders to owners sometimes these
reminders are sent to the previous owner
of the vehicle instead of the current
owner this is a problem for tax payers
who were frustrated by perceived
inefficiency
it is also a problem for the DMV who
received late payments petrol wants to
fix this but her challenge is getting
the cloud and on-premises MQ
applications to work together she
updates the tax application to send a
query to the blockchain by using the MQ
blockchain bridge she can simply place a
request message on the bridge request
queue
finally Petra modifies the existing
reminder notification processing so that
it is driven by response messages from
the bridge indicating confirmation or
change of ownership by using the MQ
blockchain bridge
Petra has been able to combine the
benefits of these two technologies to
create a solution to benefits the
business and their customers learn more
about using blockchain and mq for z/os
together at IBM vis / mq blockchain
bridge
[Music]